I've written lengthier remarks that
develop these subjects a little bit more
precisely and these are going to be
published by the Kirby sent center on
their site and a monograph produced and
in those I have a number of
recommendations concerning the
procedures of the Senate Judiciary
Committee and holding its confirmations
but most of all what I want to do by
working with Hillsdale College in the
kirby center is communicate to the
groups of people who may not be part of
the inside the the inner constitutional
sanctum what is at stake right now so
hopefully there will be more interest
communicated to their elected officials
and eventually the elected officials
particularly those in the United States
Senate and participate in this process
might take an interest in trying to
focus the confirmation hearings on these
matters I mean have been many very
disappointing confirmation hearings in
the past I thought the one with regard
to justice Sotomayor was actually a good
step in the right direction but i think
we continue to have to encourage members
of the Senate to devote even more focus
to constitutional issues I guess most of
all what I'd like in the confirmation
process would be an increasing focus not
just on judge Smith or Judge Jones who's
actually before the committee but I wish
these would be used increasingly as an
opportunity to assess the health of the
Constitution and to analyze the the
great constitutional debates of the time
to try to inquire of judicial nominees
what they think about these issues I
think there's a real misunderstanding on
the part of many senators as to what
constitutes an appropriate kind of
inquiry and many people have a lot of
confusion about that I think it's all
together appropriate to ask questions
about how judicial candidate proposes to
resolve a constitutional dispute that is
what they would look to what
the evidence that they believe would be
appropriate to consider in that process
I don't believe its proper to ask how
would you decide a particular precise
case in the future but i do believe its
proper to ask them questions about
larger contra constitutional
controversies what do you think about a
colorblind constitution this has been a
matter of debate in the United States
for the past 30 years what do you think
about a colorblind constitution what do
you think about the debate that
Professor Code defines between the
nationalist and the trans nationalist I
think these are proper entirely proper
debates now the advice and consent
process is the choke point of our
constitutional process once a judge
judicial nominee gets beyond that choke
point he's on the bench for the rest of
his life and I think it's entirely
proper for senators and I'm talking
about senators of both parties inquiring
of judicial nominees of both parties
it's entirely proper to inquire just
what kind of custodian a judicial
nominee will become if he is blessed
with this opportunity to define our
Constitution for the rest of his or her
life and I don't think senators need to
be apologetic about that I think they
need to understand this is one of the
most important responsibilities that
they carry out especially those on the
Senate Judiciary Committee